[Music]
hi I'm Dustin Kirkland and I'm here with
Saad Ali tech lead at Google for storage
in kubernetes and we're going to talk a
bit about maybe your views on some of
the big problems left to solve in the
kubernetes technical arena sure yeah so
six storage has been dealing with a
bunch of different issues most recently
around making kubernetes storage more
extensible so we authored the container
storage interface project with the goal
of making volume plugins external to
kubernetes okay the challenge so far has
been you know kubernetes we've developed
a very powerful volume subsystem but in
order to add new volume plugins you have
to actually check code into the
kubernetes core code base and that's
extremely painful for for us as
kubernetes developers because we have to
maintain and test code that we don't
write and we don't necessarily have all
the external dependencies to be able to
test it properly and it's painful for
storage vendors because they have to
align themselves with the kubernetes
release and they have to open source
code that they may not be comfortable
open sourcing so they should accelerate
a bit of the portability in the storage
layer for kubernetes exactly exactly and
what about ensuring can it do that while
still ensuring api compatibility
that is the goal so one of the reasons
we didn't want to come up with an
interface early on was it's very
difficult to predict what you what the
the user usage patterns are going to
look like and so initially we we built
everything in tree we could iterate on
it very quickly if we broke a volume
plug-in because we wanted to modify the
API we could go ahead and update those
volume plugins that were all in tree now
we've gotten to a point where we
understand what the the interface should
look like and we've gotten to a point
where we can actually go ahead and
create an interface an API that is going
to fulfill our needs right the API is
separate of course from the
implementation they actually API you
feel like it's pretty well set at this
point it still evolved
so we haven't gone to 1.0 yet and the
reason for that is because we want to
give ourselves the ability to continue
to evolve it until we're confident in it
so with kubernetes we want beta last
quarter and next quarter where we're
gonna keep it in beta and then the
quarter after that we plan to move it
into GA when we move it to GA we want to
move the interface to 1.0 is this a
problem that you look to make some
progress on perhaps this week at the
contributor summit or over the course of
the conference yeah absolutely it'll be
interesting to talk to developers
especially in the storage arena we're
actually writing volume plugins and get
their feedback on on the the interface
as it exists today and this interface is
so far in your experience it's been
portable across clouds and on Prem as
well yes the idea with the volume plugin
is that no matter what kind of storage
system whether it is a cloud storage
system could be GC persistent disks
Amazon EBS disks or on-prem if you're
running something like NFS I scuzzy or
savvy SF yeah you can write a volume
plug-in and it'll just worked and as far
as your end users of kubernetes are
concerned its abstracted away from them
so they don't have to worry about the
actual storage that's fulfilling their
workloads storage needs do you have a
perspective perhaps on maybe some of the
ways that kubernetes is helping with
storage at scale large scale yeah so I
think one of the challenges in the past
has been that storage requires the
end-user to be intimately aware of the
type of storage system that they're
using here and with kubernetes one of
the cool things it's done is it has
abstracted away things like compute
memory but also storage at least for
file and block and end user no longer
has to worry about the specific
implementations of their storage where
it comes from how it's going to scale
they can just assume that it exists and
kubernetes will make sure that it's
available wherever their workload is
scheduled and move around with it
wherever their workload is scheduled and
then what about the cross-section of the
hard problems around storage and network
right much of the storages
network-attached right so you've clearly
got to have a tight correlation with the
storage the storage saying in the
networks they have to be pretty tightly
correlated right yes a lot of the magic
that comes from being able to move your
workloads around with your storage is
due to the fact that the story just
actually network-attached that does come
in a cost if you you're networking your
storage is going over your network your
network and your network constrained it
can it can cause issues here
unfortunately in kubernetes we don't do
a great job of being able to partition
out your network i/o so sad
you've mentioned six storage a couple of
times now and it sounds like you're in
the leadership position around the
things and have been around that maybe
tell us a little bit about how the
special interest groups work in the in
the CN CF and around kubernetes and
maybe some best practices you've learned
and sure in working with that yeah so
the special interest groups and
kubernetes are designed to kind of break
this very very large project into more
manageable chunks trying to manage a
project of the size of kubernetes an
open source project where you don't have
hierarchy you don't have you know folks
who are in charge of large groups is
very difficult and so with the special
interest groups what we've tried to do
is create areas of interest where you
can have developers focused on a
specific area of kubernetes so for
example I work with cig storage and
we're responsible for the volume
subsystem of kubernetes and if someone
wanted to get involved in your sake or
another say what's that process looked
at so we hold bi-weekly meetings at
least in the storage sig side and all
the other six also have meetings that
they hold regularly and the schedules
are published on on the website and we
know that folks all over the world can't
necessarily attend no matter what time
you're gonna pick there's going to be a
time zone that isn't going to work for
people here so we encourage all six to
actually record and publish these
meetings so that if you're in a time
zone that can't attend or for whatever
and you can't attend you can catch up on
what's going on with a cig good good
that's great
yeah so it's a really interesting
community this kubernetes community I'm
curious if you have any any thoughts on
particular community members that maybe
you want to give a shout out to people
that have helped you or inspired you in
the you know in the last few months um
so I guess one of the really awesome
developers have been working with
recently is Vladimir Vivian he used to
be with the Delhi MC code team he's now
with VMware still working on kubernetes
specifically the container storage
interface project I'm super impressed
with his knowledge of the go language gr
PC and just how personable he is he
works remotely from Florida but he's
always available to answer questions and
and willing to help fix bugs and Norley
design issues part of that globally
distributed community that we're all a
part of exactly well thanks I'd thanks
very much thank you
you